[Música]
cuando comprobé que hoy estoy viva
porque mi padre tenía mala puntería me
quede congelada aquella historia no era
un mal sueño ni un cuento inventado por
mi fantasiosa mente infantil se trataba
de una realidad de un recuerdo
traumático
en ese momento sentí como si me hubieran
metido a un refrigerador que contenía el
pasado de mis padres todos sus secretos
una noche siendo yo muy niña escuché el
ruido en la planta baja
levante de mi cama muy asustada y de
puntitas me fui a asomar por el barandal
todavía puedo recordar la cara de furia
de mi padre como aventado objetos contra
las paredes empujando a mi mamá
cuando rememoró ese momento mi voz se
quiebra mis manos tiemblan y mi corazón
se acelera
no sé en qué momento mi mamá pudo
escapar de él para subir al segundo piso
y tomarme entre sus brazos para
protegerme
mi padre aprovechó ese pequeño lapso de
tiempo para ir por un rifle
camino hacia dónde estábamos nosotras se
paró de frente y a sangre fría disparó
la bala pasó justo en medio de nuestras
cabezas la adversidad había tocado a
nuestra puerta estábamos en la boca del
cocodrilo
como sobrevivientes de violencia
doméstica teníamos tres opciones la
primera era
vivir como víctimas envueltas en el
miedo y el dolor sin saber qué sería de
nosotras
la segunda a raíz de esta experiencia
convertirnos en mujeres frustradas
enojadas y tal vez violentas la tercera
era reinventarnos reconstruirnos a
través de la fuerza de la resiliencia
del amor y la ayuda de nuestra familia
ambas optamos por la tercera y digo a
ambas porque en algún momento de mi vida
tuve que elegir qué postura iba a tomar
ante estos sucesos y elegir
reconstruirme
es por eso que hoy estoy aquí con
ustedes hablando de violencia y abuso
imagina una ciudad
habitada por cocodrilos tú y yo somos
uno de ellos está sobrepoblada hay
tráfico contaminación la situación
económica se tambalea
en fin en la mañana te levantas para
iniciar tu día sales de casa y te
enfrentas al transporte público
deficiente
tienes miedo de ser asaltado
postrado violada
si tienes hijos y los llevaste a la
escuela te encuentras una larga fila y
te preguntas por qué hay una fila
resulta que están revisando mochila los
niños cocodrilos ahora llevan armas a
clase
llegas a tu oficina y tu jefe ha perdido
un proyecto importante está furioso te
grita y te quedas petrificado no es
momento de contestar le callas y te vas
a tu escritorio
suene el teléfono es tu mamá tu hermana
pequeña no llegó a dormir
su celular no lo contesta te preguntas
si estará viva o muerta
en esta ciudad hay feminicidios
así van sucediendo un hecho tras otro
sientes una angustia muy profunda para
colmo cae una pandemia sobre sus
habitantes
la muerte la enfermedad y el aislamiento
se suben al escenario como primeros
actores
incrementando aún más el abuso y la
violencia
desestabilizando todas nuestras formas
conocidas y familiares de interactuar y
de relacionarnos
plantando el miedo al contacto humano
y los cocodrilos que hacen sobrevivir
puesto que es lo que saben hacer huir
atacar o congelarse
todos los que estamos aquí en algún
momento de nuestra vida hemos sido
víctimas del ataque del cocodrilo
y si tú estás pensando en este momento
yo de ninguna manera te aseguro que en
algún momento de tu vida te dieron una
nalgada en la calle o en el transporte
alguien es una broma hiriente respecto
al color de tu piel a tu manera de
pensar tu forma de vestir o tu
orientación sexual
alguien te empujó o te volvió en la
escuela en fin esto en los casos en los
que las cosas resultaron de una manera
no tan hiriente porque en esta batalla
miles
tal vez millones de personas han perdido
la vida y los cocodrilos que habitan
esta ciudad lo que hacen es lo que saben
hacer
o se quedan congelados en las garras de
la sumisión o
no controlan sus impulsos se vuelven
violentos y atacan
es una realidad que solamente tú puedes
controlar tu conducta
no puedes controlar la conducta de los
demás pero si puedes elegir como
responder ante ella
solamente tú y yo somos responsables de
nuestro cocodrilo interno
desde esa premisa la violencia es
previsible y se puede prevenir a través
de la psicoeducación
no existe una mayor fuente de bienestar
y de felicidad que tener una conexión
honesta con otro ser humano sin
sufrimiento y sin dolor cuando lastima
algo no anda bien
desde ahí los quiero invitar a que se
pregunten quién carambas es el encargado
de arreglar este asunto y por qué no lo
ha hecho
yo también me lo he preguntado y la
respuesta es muy simple estamos
esperando que los gobiernos y las
instituciones
vengan a sacarnos de este oscuro pantano
no estamos conectados con nuestras
habilidades humanas de alto nivel
queremos un rescatador pero no va a
venir nos toca a nosotros como
individuos y como sociedad civil
tomar la responsabilidad personal de
erradicar abuso y violencia en nuestras
relaciones personales
la violencia se gesta en casa en
nuestros propios sistemas familiares a
través de la repetición de patrones de
agresividad y sexualidad mal entendidos
porque aunque estas partes son
inherentes a nosotros violencia y abuso
son una expresión inadecuada
una manera abusiva de mostrarlas por
añadidura estamos llenos de cada idea
a las mujeres nos dicen calladita te ves
más bonita quien bien te quiere te hará
llorar
a los hombres los hombres no lloran y
así el machismo corre por las venas de
nuestras familias en especial en
latinoamérica
las mujeres hemos luchado con una
incapacidad histórica por ser respetadas
de ahí nace la lucha violenta de muchas
de nosotras
de una cultura y una sociedad que
quebranta y pisotea nuestros derechos
sin embargo continuar en esa guerra
solamente traerá más de lo mismo dolor
dónde está la solución
es imprescindible en este momento que
aprendamos a cuidar nuestra salud mental
educarnos emocionalmente
ponerle nombre a nuestras emociones
y también tomar nuestra responsabilidad
personal en el asunto
porque es una realidad que ningún
gobierno va a venir a erradicar ese
problema al menos en nuestra vida
personal
necesitamos aprender a usar el cerebro
como si fuera una orquesta sinfónica hoy
les voy a brindar una herramienta psico
educativa para dar el primer paso hacia
una vida sin violencia voy a tomar
prestada la teoría del cerebro trino
nosotros tenemos tres cerebros en uno el
primero es el cerebro reptiliano aquel
del que he venido hablando que solamente
nos ayuda a sobrevivir es instintivo nos
congela o nos vuelve violentos
por supuesto que es útil siempre y
cuando esté conectado con el cerebro
límbico es el lugar en el que habitan
nuestras emociones y donde son reguladas
y muy importante el tercer cerebro el
cerebro racional aquel que va a ser el
director general de nuestra mente va a
pensar nuestros instintos a razonar las
emociones las va a nombrar ubicar a
nuestras necesidades y de ahí nuestra
conducta podrá ser asertiva es decir
estar en equilibrio entre la violencia y
la pasividad
les voy a dar un ejemplo de desconexión
que nos pasa a muchos
hoy en la mañana amanecí con un hueco en
el estómago y fui por una caja de
galletas a la cocina me las comí pero el
hueco seguía ahí regresé a la cocina
abría el congelador saqué un litro de
helado me lo comí y el hueco ahí seguía
instalado ahí pues pedí desde mi celular
unos tacos me los comí y el hueco estaba
ahí
cuando llegó mi esposo dijo encantado
porque si hubiera tomar una copa casa de
un amigo yo me puse como una pantera le
dije que era un idiota un imbécil que
como se le ocurría ir a tomar una copa
si estábamos en plena pandemia
salió de la casa y azotó la puerta
si yo regreso el casete a esa mañana y
hubiera estado conectada las cosas
hubieran sido muy diferentes
si hubiera pensado mi sensación corporal
un hueco en el estómago era angustia
y hubiera razonado cuál era mi necesidad
cuidarme porque tengo miedo de
contagiarme de ahí sabría que hoy estoy
angustiada porque tengo miedo de
enfermarme de kobe y cuando lo hubiera
llegado yo podría haberle dicho ay por
favor de otro día porque la verdad es
que hoy estoy muy angustiada porque no
me quiero contagiar
y me hubiera dado un atracón ni lo
hubiera insultado
que hubiera hecho él no lo sé porque su
conducta es
su responsabilidad lo mismo pasa con el
enojo y con la ira cuando sientas ese
dolor de cabeza ese fuego que te invade
porque vas a explotar en ese momento
ubique el sentimiento razona lo
encuentra tu necesidad y de ahí elige la
conducta más asertiva
por eso digo que está en nuestras manos
cambiar las cosas si nuestra
participación
nunca cambiaremos lo en cambiable a lo
largo de esta charla acarició la idea de
que no usamos nuestras habilidades
mentales y humanas de alto nivel y que
estamos fundidos en un oscuro pantano
desde ahí no podemos esperar a que otra
persona venga a vivir nuestra vida por
nosotros la vida es lo único que no
acepta representantes
sin embargo
desde la premisa de que todos podemos
recuperar la voluntad de vivir la
autoestima y la salud mental si está en
tus manos hacer algo
yo como sobreviviente aprendí de niña a
siempre levantarme de las caídas y que
las tormentas por duras largas y oscuras
que sean siempre tienen un final sin
embargo ese final depende de lo que tú
hagas
el silencio es lo que hace que la
violencia y el abuso se reproduzcan como
si fueran hongos es su mejor caldo de
cultivo
rompan los
todas las historias de los que estamos
hoy aquí son dignas de ser contadas
muchas gracias